everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today I want to do
a recap of the project that we just
launched and go over like how we did it
the decisions that we made why we made
them and then talk a little bit about
the next steps for for what's gonna
happen I also have some nice analytics
to share with you just about you know
how well the site's doing and so we're
not really gonna do a lot of coding
right now it's gonna be more like just
kind of overview also you know feel free
to ask questions definitely open to
questions and also I want to give you a
little update on like my situation for
work and everything cuz there's gonna be
some changes coming up so that's the
plan for today sorry for the short
notice on the stream - I I was just
really busy and didn't I wanted to
stream but I didn't get it scheduled
early enough so there maybe had been
some issues with notifications not being
received
but hopefully looks like you know
there's a lot of you in the stream so
I'm hoping that everything works with
the notifications okay so first let me
explain some of the the changes right I
don't want to leave anybody in suspense
right so I am most likely going to be
leaving my position right now
at the University and finding employment
somewhere else so if you follow me on
social media you probably already know
this I've I've received already
thankfully a lot of not not direct
offers but a lot of invitations to apply
to places and offers from people to to
recommend me so I'm very grateful for
that and thank you so much to everyone
who who retweeted my tweet or shared it
on on Instagram or on
LinkedIn thank you so much for that the
the response and the reach that that got
is just amazing and like I'm very very
grateful thank you thank you so much for
that so I don't know where I'll be at
and I'm not sure how quickly I'll be
I'll be leaving here so for now I I
guess I'll still be working on this
project and I'm still gonna do my stream
so I'm gonna I'm gonna keep it on my
stream and then depending on what
position I get we just have to see I'd
love to keep doing the stream it may be
that I won't be able to stream my
everyday work but I'll have to stream a
side project and it may be you know
maybe the stream has to have some move
too like a Saturday or maybe it's going
to be in the evenings instead of in the
morning so so they're they're probably
gonna be some changes to the stream but
not just yet I'll still be streaming
although next next week I may not be
able to stream that much because I will
be at react training in Washington DC so
I'm excited about that to learn some new
stuff so just to give you a little heads
up to about why why this is happening
so as you all most of you know who have
watched the stream this project we've
been working on since January has
launched look launched like two to three
weeks ago but if you go to the website
now if you go to the URL you'll see the
old website so unfortunately is somebody
higher up in the organization for some
reason unknown to me didn't like the
website and instructed the IT department
to change it back to the old website and
this was all without consulting me so at
this point I don't know what the problem
was I have some guesses but
just based on stuff I've heard from
other people so I don't know why the
site was taken down I've gotten no
attempt to contact me to explain
anything or to ask me to change anything
as we'll see in a second the site was
definitely meeting the requirements and
surpassing them it was based on the
analytics it was already hitting our
goals for what we wanted the site to do
and as far as this this person that made
the call didn't even look at the
analytics I from from everything I
understand about it the call was made
without without that so and this person
is actually someone new to the
organization and hasn't even been
involved in the process so this is
pretty like kind of disturbing to me and
so I mean that was okay that was it's
definitely a hit to the ego but what
really pushed me over the edge is just
the way it all happened from what I
understand you know the people who did
actually get to talk to this person
say he was he was not very nice about
the whole thing
treated treated people in a way that no
one should be treated right so given
that I just don't feel comfortable being
around if you know one of the main
people in charges is treating people
like that
so what I'll do is I'm going to try to
make sure that people know about it
hopefully somebody will do something
about it but you know at the end of the
day it's it's not environment that I
want to be in so while I'm still here
I'm gonna do whatever I can to try to
make it better for the people that are
staying but then I you know I got to get
out it's so like you know personally you
know I struggle with depression and
anxiety and things so oh this hasn't
been not feeling very good the last
couple of days I'm pretty calm now I
actually have a really bad headache so
when I get anxiety usually that caffeine
makes it worse
so I totally cut caffeine out yesterday
and I've been getting these headaches I
think maybe I was drinking too much
caffeine and now I'm going through
withdrawal so my head hurts so bad right
now but I know based on my past
experience situations like this could
make me have a panic attack so I don't
want to chance that so I'm just trying
to be as calm as I can and just keep
doing what I'm doing you know talking to
people about new job opportunities and
you know thinking about okay how do I
want to work my resume you know I'm
thinking about maybe redoing my personal
website since I haven't touched it in
years you know been talking with my wife
about what we want to do and been
thinking about ways to just address the
situation in the most professional way
possible without glad see there are
several options like I could freak out
and be very unprofessional about this or
I could just try to hide and I don't
want to do either right I don't want to
hide because I don't want this to happen
to other people in the organization and
I don't want to freak out because
that'll pray make things worse so I'm
trying to find a middle ground to get
the word out in a very logical way to
the people that need to know and and
make a good case for for not only this
site but for you know for making sure
that people are treated with respect so
yeah so I am anyway and I it's it was
just one person
right so this is not like a huge
organizational thing you know I
generally over my three years here you
know 99% of people have been very
friendly you know just even over the top
like beyond what you'd expect people to
be so this is a new individual here
unfortunately they have a lot of
authority so I don't I don't really know
this person I haven't even gotten a
chance to know them
I'm not I'm not even sure what to think
about it you know other than it
shouldn't it shouldn't no one should
ever treat another person like that okay
so let's get on to this site is some
happier stuff I'm actually still like
I'm really proud of this site despite
what this other person may think like
objectively speaking we did a good job
with this site the the technology is
sound it's you know somewhat cutting
edge I think we accomplished what our
goals were right so if someone wanted to
disagree with what the goals were in the
first place
you know that's understandable they
could do that but in terms of does this
website meet the goals does it does it
meet this is fulfill the requirements of
the project I think most definitely it
does so let's check out the analytics
first and let me give you if you're not
sure what website I'm talking about this
is the one that we built I still have it
up at a at a test link that I had
running anyway so I'd never took down
the test link and I just want to say hi
I see a lot of activity in the chat so
let me let me switch up to this screen
you can see it for a second and I just
want to say hello to everyone so hey I
see there are some questions I'll get to
some of the the more like technical
questions in a second but I want to
answer any questions that have to do
with what we just talked about first
Karl asked if I'd still in my live
stream no matter what I do want to try
as hard as I can to keep doing this live
stream as long as you all think that
it's valuable to you and to the
community I will I want to keep doing it
yes even says so no feedback no mock-up
changes with the heck yeah I mean that's
it's it's a it's an unprecedented
situation I've never had this happen
before you know for someone to be
dissatisfied with with your work but
then give absolutely no feedback marius
says thank you for being open I want you
all to know what's really going on you
know when I say this even though this is
live and anybody could watch it like it
doesn't feel like I'm just announcing
this to the public right like we've all
been together many of us for you know
well over a year working on projects you
know so you're you know we have a
community here you know we have a team
here so you all deserve to know why the
work that you some of you have actually
contributed code and many of you
contributed ideas so this is all very
much our work why it's not there anymore
and it says that person acts very mature
we are supporting you in your decision
thank you thank you so much I appreciate
it
okay all right so let's let's check out
then some of the analytics and then
maybe we'll see what it looks like in
terms of questions in there and maybe go
over some stuff so I'm gonna make this
as big as I can but here's the analytics
that I I was impressed I was honestly
surprised at how good some of these
numbers were I mean I know it's one
thing to have an idea and a plan and and
know you know have a good idea that it
will work and it's another thing to
actually see the results so I'm gonna go
over these really quick especially for
those you who are just listening I can't
read this I took the analytics and I
actually removed Steubenville the city
that the university is in from the
results right because I the target
audience is not people are
on campus and most of our students don't
actually come from Steubenville so we
remove student about completely so I
compared the same time period in 2017 to
the time period the website was live
because we're trying to track like
applications and that's very cyclical so
the only way to be fair about it is the
same time period in in that same year
right so we had sixty-seven percent
decrease in page load times right which
was expected right we knew it was gonna
be a lot faster homepage even greater
decrease the next number I think is
really important so we're targeting
prospective students right we want them
to come to our website we want them to
apply to learn more about this
University so Google Analytics doesn't
let you it doesn't show you data
specifically about people under 25 but
you can tell because if you just take
the total number of visits - all the
visits from the age groups they do give
you data from which starts at 25 and
goes up to however high somebody can
live - then we can get a better idea of
okay well the group that's left over is
younger than 25 they are most likely
majority made up of people who are in
that group that age group of our target
audience so anyway we have a 48%
increase in people visiting our site
from that from that age group which is
great because that's what we were we had
in mind the entire time we had an
increase in visits to the application of
7% increase which is a really nice a
nice increase I need to get the data on
the inquiry form - I forgot to do that
but that's also an important form that
we're trying to drive people to we
actually had a big increase in the time
spent on the homepage which is
interesting because the old homepage was
huge it took very long a long time to
load partly because there's so much
content I mean very small text images
videos everywhere and you could scroll
for three
it was long you can see it now at the
main website it you know the old website
is back online now but the interesting
thing is we got rid of all that and had
a very minimal simplistic homepage and
we had an increase of peoples of the
time spent on the homepage by 48 percent
and you know from just looking at that
yeah it face value you kind of trying to
figure out why you know I think the
busyness of the old homepage was a
turn-off it was overwhelming and when we
actually broke it down and only showed
people some very important facts they
they stayed and they read those so there
may be other ways to interpret that but
that seems like a pretty good way to
kind of view that statistic to me and
it's almost counterintuitive right we we
gave them less content and then they
ended up spending more time on the page
also I'm not going to go through every
department but you like one of the big
things we wanted to do is show that we
have good academic programs here where
we are a Catholic school and we have a
well-known reputation for being Catholic
so based on our market research we
already know that that people don't
doubt that but what people doubt is our
academics they don't know if we're
actually good academically so there are
students that would like to come here
because they're Catholic students and
they won't they want to be here but
they're not sure they'll get a good
education here so what we were trying to
do is appeal to those students by
showcasing our academic programs right
on the homepage and you know we
succeeded in bringing in more people so
you can see the Masters in theology had
a bit of an increase some of these like
theology program had a two hundred
seventy five percent increase in traffic
to that page so you can see just some of
the other programs here some really big
numbers here huge increases so you know
based on these analytics I think we
definitely succeeded in in our goals for
this website
and and this was just really the first
phase I mean you all know there are so
many ideas from what we wanted to do
that are gonna come later on or we're
gonna come later on probably not now so
really this is comparing a site that had
already gone through a whole year
development from an all-agency working
on it and talking about the old site and
then years of development after that
comparing it to a site that just came
out and you know basically we've done
just kind of me and you all have done
for less than a year launched it and had
very little time to make any
improvements and we still had these kind
of numbers I mean that to me I think
that's that's very impressive I'm proud
of it I think you all should be proud of
it because you're a big part of it so no
matter what happens with this site this
is a successful site and the data shows
it you you can't you can't argue the the
numbers so anyway I wanted to share that
with you because I think that's it's
just so impressive and you know all the
thought that we put into this site and
you know everything it paid off okay let
me I guess I don't need to show anything
right now let's just put this in the
background because we're just going to
talk about stuff for a little bit so I'm
gonna take a little bit of time right
now to answer some of the questions that
you have and then we're going to dive
into some of the technology just to
refresh your mind in case you haven't
been watching these streams this was
built with react with next j/s we're
using a palo graph QL we use node
WordPress for the content management
system with a WP graph QL plug-in we
have algo Lea now for search which I did
finish and implemented so you can try
out the search now it's way faster we're
using Google cloud platform to host most
of this cloud sequel
and what do you have class sequel the
the cloud storage bucket and we're using
App Engine to host the react app we're
using digitalocean
for the WordPress application or the
WordPress installation
so all those technologies went into this
so if you have questions about any of
technologies why we use them or anything
feel free to put them in there now I can
go into a lot more detail about it a
harsh it's here and will only be around
here for a few minutes says now all we
need is a good SVG loader for the
loading screen yeah for sure I am I
thought about that the other night you
know sometimes you just think about a
project at night time you know even
working on it it just occurred to me
like we still have the words loading
come up when you look like we never
actually put a real loader in there and
we did on the on the search page so I
thought well at the very least we can
just grab what we did on the search page
and then put that in for the loader on
all the other pages in place of the
words loading so that'll probably be on
the list
but once again I don't really know how
much more work I'll be doing on this
unfortunately because you know we still
had a lot of good things that could have
been done
so let me I'm gonna scroll up and answer
some questions here
setec said is it possible to build a
Kickstarter clone with react is almost
definitely yeah you can definitely do
that in react I I think probably any
site on the internet could be redone in
in react because it's it's javascript in
HTML and CSS which is what everything's
built out of it doesn't even matter what
the backend is really so you could you
could remake really anything you know
any UI you know whatever in react
components
ramani says how to make a big web app
with react I mean if you're going to
make something a big one it's I you can
definitely do it with react I would just
if it's going to be really large
structure is important so in that case I
would most definitely think about
reusability of your components so like
your actual codebase can remain small
and easy to work with
sometimes in smaller projects and I know
we've done it in the in we've done it in
this project sometimes as we'll say ah
you know what we could really refactor
this and reuse it but let's just get
this done quick and do it and then you
may or may not ever go back and redo
that
now if the project starts to grow and
grow and grow that could really make
things difficult to navigate and your
project could just balloon and your
codebase gets huge so I would be more
care if you know right up off the bat
it's going to be a very big project then
you should be more careful about things
like that like how are you gonna handle
that structure and things like that and
make sure that that's all planned out so
that you don't have those moments where
you just say ah you know we could do it
like this but it'll be faster to do this
you know it you can get away with that
when it's not that large but you on a
large application it could down the road
not be good for you
so if you have any that's kind of really
like a large topics you have any
specific questions you know please let
me know
DIY coder says the work is really good
appreciate this hard work but using
reactor making website is this overkill
or it's just the way to do it yeah I
mean you could say this is overkill
we definitely you know we could have
built this website using something else
right you could I would say this though
like I would I have no idea how I would
have worked out all the routing for this
if we were doing this and let's say just
plain JavaScript and I had to do like I
don't know I used like jQuery for my to
do custom routing it would have been
insane it's already insane using you
know react state management would have
been a huge problem so this website in
particular we had so much content coming
over like it let's just say for instance
I try to do it in WordPress that also
would have been a huge thing in terms of
making sure all the URLs work right it
would have been it I think it would have
been very challenging and difficult to
do this in in other in other ways so in
this particular case even though it's
just a website being able to use react
in the whole react ecosystem helped me a
lot but you're right normally for a
website react is potentially overkill
although to be honest with you if you
use create react app to start up a
website really quickly it's it's really
easy to build out a site with react you
know potentially even easier than if you
were to just do straight HTML CSS
vanilla JavaScript site now it depends
like if you're not used to react of
course react is going to be really
difficult but you know it's it's so the
barrier to entry for react is so low now
and that's a good thing
that you know it doesn't feel like
overkill right to build anything in
reacts so yeah so I would yeah I would
say for a regular website it potentially
could be overkill but it's not like it's
not the end of the world right if you
give do something in in react at least
that's that's the way I feel right it's
it all depends on your project with the
resources or how much time you're going
to take and what your level of ability
is with it right then I'm sorry if I'm
not as with it as I normally am it's
just my headache is I tried it hey
something killer so my headache is not
getting better at all
Lambada says i'm new year thanks in
advance for sharing I'm in need of
inspiration to study on oh well thank
you so much for watching and welcome and
yeah for inspiration I I would just say
I want to say like keep that I keep
getting better every day you'll be
amazed at how far you've come in a month
you know in a year you'll look back and
it it'll be it'll be like wow I you know
like I couldn't do I couldn't even think
about doing what I'm doing now a year
ago you know you you'll hit that moment
and it feels really good alright Anoop
says which is better angular or react
it definitely def
someone wants the old website link I'm
going to type it in right now okay so
the old website which is now live in
place of this one I just linked here so
you can check out the old website it may
take a while to load okay so the
question was angular versus react it all
depends on your situation on your
project on what you're good with you can
build really awesome things or really
terrible things with either one so the
way to go is just look at the strengths
and weaknesses of react and angular and
look at what you need to do for your
project and the strengths and weaknesses
that you have or your team has and then
you pick which would you have to pick so
it's it's not a an answer that you can
give a blanket answer over everything
right it definitely depends on specifics
hopefully that makes sense I know it
doesn't help it's easier if you can just
have this is the best thing go with it
but that's not really how this this
works
Ambala says trying to understand why
next Jas is needed okay the reason we
went with next Jas is for server-side
rendering is so if you're not familiar
with next Jas its it works with react
right so you you run next Jas it builds
out the basics bare-bones of all your
react project it handles your webpack
config and it gives you a basic like
file structure and it handles routing
for you in this case we have custom
routing but normally it handles the
routing for you but what it does that is
really awesome is server-side rendering
by default why do we need server-side
rendering because search engines won't
be able to see your content right so
they won't stick around long enough to
wait to make the API call to get the
data back and display it on the page
rake all client-side but when you render
on the server what gets sent to the
search engines when they come to your
site and anybody else who comes to your
site for they get HTML HTML CSS right
all there and then after that what next
will do is offer client-side routing so
you really get the best of both worlds
you get that server-side routing for
that really fast initial load time and
the the ability for search engines to
see your content and then after that you
get that speed of it actually prefetches
content so that when a user clicks on a
link sometimes they actually have
instantaneous load so the zero second
load time because the data is already
there so really awesome it definitely
helps out right I I would not want to
have to handle all the stuff that it
does in the background on my own so they
do a great job it's it's updated so
frequently and
very very reliable Zubair says is this
project going to be an app react native
excellent well it's it's a progressive
web app so that's what we ended up
building Max is a Python still good idea
to learn yeah absolutely there's a lot
of good work in machine learning
happening with Python as far as I know
so it depends on what you're into what
you want to work with but you know
Python is definitely worthwhile Marcia
says hey Jesse thank you for doing this
you're welcome
great value question how do I know that
I'm ready to start learning a framework
from your perspective of course if you
have a good understanding of HTML CSS
and at least basic JavaScript then I
would say go ahead and learn the
framework especially if there's a
project that you want to use it with you
think it would be beneficial it can
definitely help it can help you make
some good stuff you know faster than you
you wouldn't otherwise be able to if
there's a framework that you know would
look really good on your resume then
that's you know that's a great bonus to
to be able to have that on there if
you've worked with it so just make sure
though that you keep up your skills so
as you're using this framework try not
to get locked in too much depending on
the framework it's it's easier or harder
to do that but make sure you jot your
vanilla JavaScript skills still improve
right you're in CSS HTML is still
improves so as long as you're doing that
and not really locking yourself in I
think you're fine of course if you want
to lock yourself in you know go ahead
and do it but it does it may make it a
bit harder down the road if that
particular framework falls out of
fashion it may make it harder to switch
if you don't keep up with some of the
other stuff hopefully it answered your
question
it says Harsha by the way Franciscan dot
e-d-u going to the old site for me is it
removed maybe I missed something
beginning yeah yeah okay let me paste
this this is our [ __ ] you did miss
something so if you want to at some
point if you have time go back and watch
the first couple of minutes but
basically the short story is the old
website is back up and the new website
that we made has been taken down but you
can still see it at that the link that I
just pasted it in
Michael creo says I want to watch live
but I really want to know what's
happened since yesterday so you go back
can you go back and rewind and just
watch the first ten minutes and then
come back you watch it on double speed
and you'll catch up I guess
ruch Russia kesh sorry if I'm
mispronouncing this but they say I'm
just a beginner in web development
before react what should I learn or
clear my basics yeah HTML CSS JavaScript
focus on those if you're a beginner and
and and you'll be fine with that
and then whenever you need to use a
framework and you start working on more
complex things when a framework will
really help you then jump into that
framework Phoenix says hey Jesse what's
up congratulations I guess I can say
that now right also I saw your Instagram
status was this a contract project no so
I explained a lot of it in more detail
in the first 10 minutes of the stream
but just you know long story short I
will be I'm going to leave my position
you know I'm most likely going to leave
my position here at the University and
find another job so if you want to know
why that's happening what's the first
ten minutes of this video see shangzhou
I'm not sure I pronounce that apology's
says I'm currently only comforted with
HTML CSS and JavaScript for the front
and part how do I get the big picture
when it comes to web development like
how does the front end talk to the back
end yeah I would say you know probably
look up some tutorials and courses if
you go through the free code camp
lessons at some point it transitions
into that you know after you learn a lot
of the front-end stuff so that'll give
you a good idea about
how that that part works yeah so I mean
you don't have to go through everything
but if you just kind of skip to that
part and kind of look over what's going
on that may give you a good idea about
what to focus in on more you know to be
able to find some videos or your
tutorials about it
super says what database are you using
my sequel WordPress API yeah so we have
my sequel and we're using the REST API
and actually are we even using that
anymore I think we're all graph QL now
we did use the REST API for search but
now we switch to l Golia for search so
now I think we're using graph QL with
WordPress so we used a plug-in called WP
graph QL to be able to use graph QL with
it
Michael creo says there's no such thing
it's just the website yeah
so it's more it's really hot my office
so I'm gonna start my fan on low so if
it's too noisy let me know but it's like
it's insanely odd Zeiss need a new
little fan
it says Swan says hey Jessie why have
you chose react instead of polymer or
vue.js for example okay really good
question
so let's see I don't know very much at
all about polymer so it wasn't even
really on my radar as a possibility I
knew a little bit about view but I had
never used it before on on a project and
when we first started working on this
project the timeline was very condensed
we ended up getting a very big extension
on the timeline but you know a lot of
the reasons for that are determined by
people you know higher up above me in
the organization so when we initially
started I needed to go with something
that I already knew and we had already
built several things in react we already
had a lot of code that I could knew I
could reuse so that's why we ended up
one with react had I had all the time in
the world to learn and try something
else I'm not sure if I would have gone
with react I think it definitely worked
in this situation so I'm not saying
react was the absolute best way to go
for this but given the constraints of
the project it was the way to go for us
for this for this project Lim Bala says
what you just said there helps me a lot
Oh awesome really glad I can help nobody
says you may not remember me but I do
remember you you may not remember me but
last year I used to pop on these streams
and you inspired me to take programming
what a year now I am I'm now a semi
software engineer working in a real
react project Oh awesome I'm so glad you
came back and told me that and I I do I
remember I remember I remember the name
at least of you coming in here and
talking so that's so cool
I love it whenever I hear things like
that so that's really awesome if you get
a chance pop back in sometime and you
know let me know how your projects going
Nizar says how are you I'm okay I'm okay
I've been better a lot of stuff going on
right now you can watch the first 10
minutes of this video if you want to
know more about what's happening but
like right now I have a really really
bad headache it just keeps getting worse
so but other than that I guess I can't
complain I had a great life and for
healthy children and so I shouldn't
complain you know it could be a lot
worse
DIY coder says yes component reuse is a
huge plus and routing also yeah for sure
definitely agree with that
Harshit says a bully I search for now it
is going to be expensive I lost my place
it's an expensive monetary cost there
yeah hard [ __ ] so right now I'm just on
the essentials plan so the lowest-paid
plan and since the site's not live it's
not going to be a big deal for now but
yeah for the time that was live I was
trying to monitor it sorry
I lost my train of thought I'm really
sorry oh when I did when the site was
live I had my dashboard for boliya up
all the time on all my computers so I
always knew what was happening
Lisa II just feel better thank you I
appreciate it
come on Lawrence code says hi there have
a nice day everyone hey how's it going
thanks I hope you have a nice day as
well
Phoenix says also since the time I
started working on my blog site I have
learned it about learning I've had a ton
of learning and the things that can go
wrong are endless also it's now that I
realize how important good a good
documentation is yeah yeah documentation
is good I often slack on the
documentation myself but that's a good
point
Limbaugh says Wow awesome I really
needed this cool I'm glad you like this
Carrabba says the old site looks dated
it does it really does it was very
surprising to me when they switched back
because it was pretty much unanimous
from everybody I talked to that they did
not like the old site so and and you
know it was pretty much the consensus
that like anything would be an
improvement as long as it was faster so
yeah I was I was very surprised by
our [ __ ] says I just remember did you
enable materialized CSS minification
before prod command you in the page and
check if not that will speed the page up
by another 5% okay
that is a good tip I don't even remember
I don't recall ever doing that let's see
see their sources styles
yeah that's not it
we were
you know it's not I'm wondering like
where our bundled Styles coming from I
don't think it's this no that's not it
this is our just tiny bit of CSS which
actually I didn't minify that either
anyway I don't know how to check that
out but that's good and see that's the
thing to like the site was very fast and
we hadn't we done almost nothing to
optimize the speed right like even the
images were aren't optimized we didn't
run them through image compression or
anything like that it was just so it was
fast so all that stuff was gonna come
later but you know shaving so much time
off that loads on by switching the site
was worth it even if it wasn't
completely as a hundred percent
optimized as it could be it was still
really good I'm longing to learn his
code says I've heard about koa Jas can
you explain the purpose of this
technology briefly thanks teachers I
don't really know very much at all about
Cola so I am sorry about that but I I
don't know enough to to give a good
explanation if anybody else knows
anything about Cola please let me know
Roland says Woody's react I don't have
any idea of this react is a JavaScript
library for building web apps and you
can build other things with it too
yeah that's pretty it's like the basic
concept of react so yeah so it helps you
to build to build websites and web apps
and it's very helpful with things like
state management
Harshit says okay it says college is
server-side framework built by the same
people working on Express Jessie might
not know about it cuz he mostly just
front-end your you're absolutely right
Co is used for making performant api's
okay cool thanks I should mad Esther
says good morning all good morning thank
you for for watching and stuff and then
allow chat limbo is a game says is
access fus part of the same app or
completely separate app it is completely
separate so it's actually run by an
entirely different company different
servers everything I don't have access
to it although I was able to send a
stylesheet to this company and have them
upload it so I was able to adjust the
Styles a bit make it a little bit more
like material design style and but that
was that was about it is it's pretty
limited
modesta says a best of luck in your
transition Jessie thank you so much I
appreciate it
Roland says I'm curious about react
nodes something like that even though I
don't know any of those yeah it's a
react is a JavaScript library to build
things like maybe like on the client
side like front-end stuff node is using
javascript on the back end so server
side JavaScript
AIH says graph QL so uh
graph qo it's in query language right so
normally if you wanted to get well
there's several ways to get data right
but one way to get data to your
front-end is to use an API right and in
the standard right now is kind of like
rest api's it's like a method of
creating an API getting data from it but
the latest thing is graph QL and the
domain differences with a REST API you
pre build these these API endpoints and
when you send request to the endpoint
you will get back a certain amount of
data in a certain structure based on
what was already you know premade for
that endpoint to give you in graph QL
when you send the request you tell graph
QL exactly what data you want and it
sends you back just that data all right
no more no less so you you can end up
making less API calls because right you
don't have to have multiple endpoints to
get all the data you want and then the
total amount of data that gets
transferred is less because you just get
what you want so it is in that respect
graph QL is most definitely you know
better than a REST API in terms of how
you build it on the back end I don't
know enough about that to really know
the pros and cons of it all but that's
kind of I guess the the most concise way
I can put your word is graph kyo what is
the difference between graph yuo and a
rest api
Roland says where can I learn PHP a lot
of places I guess maybe if you really
knew try out like code Academy they have
these like interactive courses I've done
some of their courses before I almost
positive they have a PHP course I would
check that out first
Michael says ok I'll watch later from
the beginning just don't burn any
bridges that you might need later it's
always darkest before the dawn that is
good advice I appreciate that thanks
Michael man testa says I'll feel better
Jesse I hope so thanks Janet Limbaugh
says health and long life to you all
thank you thank you and you too John f
says how did freaked out camp contact
you about streaming here I started doing
live streaming on my own channel and I
did a few live streams and I knew that I
didn't really know what I was doing so I
posted in the free code camp forum a
link to my live streams and I asked if
anybody would be able to give me advice
on how to do a better job and Bo Karns
who does a ton of Awesome JavaScript
tutorial videos for free code camp
contacted me and asked if I'd be
interested in live coding for free code
camp and then shortly afterwards I also
talked to Quincy who's the head of free
code camp and then I just started doing
live streams and they went well people
watch them you know Quincy and Bo like
them so here I am today I was still
doing the streams
see why Marcio says thank thanks for
answering my questions I hope you keep
doing this kind of live question
answerer take some Advil and rest ah
thanks
they say for that advice I think I
probably will just go home after this
dream and and relax a little bit
nobody says yes I'll pop back more often
I can now start to understand what was
going on unlike last year thank you
all right cool very cool Stephen says
hey Jesse I Twitter message you Austin
Texas as a ton of react jobs available
indeed you ship roosterteeth etc all
here oh really cool thank you so much
James Howell says hope you feel better
if you have time exercise oh yeah that's
true I didn't get my regular workout in
today or yesterday so I need to work out
like today or else oh I'm gonna it's
definitely gonna impact my mental health
if I if I quit with my workouts
[Music]
AIH says is routing there in both react
and ojs yes yes so we have both server
side and client side routing Stephen
says plus pay the bar says plus pay is
way higher in Austin yeah that's for
sure well one thing is I'm almost
guaranteed to be paid more at a new
position that I am paid here higher
education doesn't necessarily at a
non-profit institution doesn't really
pay as well as other other industries
Limbaugh law says is there a video where
you talk much about price to maintain an
app this size yes so an app like this
right now and while it was live I
believe we were spending maybe like five
hundred dollars a month on all the
hosting and everything that goes with
that in that five on it might have been
a little bit overkill because I didn't
want the site to go down or slow up so
it potentially after the site had been
live for a while we could check the
analytics and fine-tune things we might
have been able to get that cost down a
little bit more but that cost includes a
server a droplet on digitalocean cloud
sequel database and Google cloud
platform also on Google cloud platform
App Engine instances and storage buckets
and then included with that cost is also
the cost of the algo Lea search service
there are a few other things we want I
wanted to add in that would have cost
more so wanted add in century for air
tracking and I also wanted to add a CDN
so those would have brought the price up
a bit more maybe another 100 bucks or so
maybe 200 depending on the traffic
she even says G fuel coffee I know I'm
trying to cut out caffeine but man maybe
I should just be I should just give in
he's gonna Cafe Jiang Yan song sorry
about the name says hello it's 2:00 a.m.
in Korea first time to watch a live and
ask a question what would you recommend
a study before learning reacted to
someone already asked sorry for
answering this again
yeah no problem it's a I learn HTML CSS
and JavaScript and that's that's all you
need before you learn react her shirt
says just watch the first 10 minutes
feel better thank you I appreciate it
Amelia know says hi Jessie here from
Argentina greetings hey how's it going
thanks for watching
Cedric says greetings from Nigeria say
Chang Hyun says thanks actually I'm
studying JavaScript but was just
wondering is this more ya know Java
scripts good you know and then you
should be able to jump into react it'll
take a little time to get used to it but
if you're solid with JavaScript then you
know go ahead and jump in
[Music]
let's see five I'm not sure how to
pronounce this uh-huh
but anyway this is which frame shirt
framework should I use for back-end
I don't know I mean I like Express would
you consider expressive framework I'm
not really sure what to call it but I
usually use a note and Express I've been
I mean it really just depends on like a
lot of factors for what you're trying to
do which course is better today's
generation I'm not exactly sure what
you're asking so maybe clarify that a
little bit please and I can I can answer
Oh harsh it's saying click view source
of course why wouldn't I remember a view
source cuz I only use view source when I
accidentally click it when I'm trying to
hit inspect and yeah it looks like it's
not even minified well that's awesome
I'm actually really happy about that
because that means we can make this even
faster cool
Phoenix says I would like this
opportunity to thank you for all these
streams that that you did I stumbled on
this on my worst times and I have been
better and hooked ever since
oh thank you for saying that I'm so glad
that that this dream is as helps you out
and thanks for being there I know you
you know you contribute a lot to the
chat and things I really appreciate that
this one says first thanks for answering
my question I watched the part where you
explained why you callate be strong man
you you're amazing I hope you know it
that guy's just allergic to intellect
good luck cool with ya I actually didn't
I didn't quit yet so like I'm in my
office right now so I'm gonna be here
for a little while longer so I have no
idea how much longer it just it depends
I guess on when I find something else
and and what have I don't think that I'm
gonna get fired over anything but yeah
so I don't know exactly how long I'll be
here but I haven't exactly quit yet but
it's not it's not a secret that I'm
looking for other employment the head of
my department knows there's actually
other people the university they're
helping me look for for new work so it's
I'm okay talking about it Phoenix says
you are also one of the major reasons
that I went ahead and loved development
the way you just dive into new tech
framework and then make things work is
amazing
Thanks I can appreciate that they don't
always work but sometimes you try things
out it doesn't work but yeah it's it's
fun I mean this work is awesome it's so
fun you get to try out new things all
the time and even if it doesn't work
like it's still fun and you learn
something right and and a lot of times
it does work and it's really awesome
I want to learn css3 - a dope level from
where should I learn it hey well I mean
you could it depends on where you're at
right now if you're just starting out
check out the free code camp lessons if
you're a little bit more advanced then I
don't really know there's probably some
some good CSS books on videos of his
online tutorials advanced CSS hmm I'm
not exactly sure if anybody has any that
if you know of any really advanced CSS
tutorials please let us know in the chat
or in the comments if you're watching
this later don don she says hey Jesse
what do you think about the Python
framework Django for web development
thank you in advance keep up the good
work I don't know very much at all about
Django I've heard of it and that's about
it so apologies for that I just I just
don't know enough to give you a good
answer Limbaugh Louis says $500 ouch
thanks thanks to the detailed answer
yeah I mean 500 is a I would say not
that much at all for a larger
organization I mean like the university
employees like four or five hundred
people you know so for organization that
size $500 a month is not not really that
much you know we probably spend more
than that on water electricity internet
like pretty much every other thing that
we have
whoa
warriors while I'm really sorry I'm
having trouble pronouncing this why why
are you sorry
I says hey Jessie I'm experienced with
react yes nodejs a MongoDB how do I come
up with ideas for side projects that
have potential generate income in future
and become sort of I don't know that's
that's if if I knew a really good answer
to that question then I'd probably do it
too but yeah I mean I would say if
you're looking for good ideas of things
that people actually want to use so you
can make money from just ask people
around you like what what do you wish
you could do like what would things in
your life do you wish could be automated
or enhance or somehow with you know
something on your phone or whatever
right think about what you do every day
like is there something you could build
that would help you
odds are if you build something and it
helps you it'll probably help other
people so think that's a good place to
start right and then if you build it
nobody wants it well at least you build
something cool that'll help you out
right so you haven't lost everything
right Bo corn says I came in late and
just watch the beginning of stream I'm
so excited to hear that Jesse the jesse
is looking isn't looking for a job
because he was fired Jesse's awesome
thank you thank you so much about yeah
yeah I was not fired I don't think I
will end up being fired oh it was not it
was not fired so this is of my own free
will
Matt duchesses vitamin B works better
than caffeine yeah you're right actually
I think I do have some vitamin B pills
at home so maybe I'll just take that
when I go home
okay so then one of the names I couldn't
pronounce is Siddharth but it's it's
written with like half in in numbers so
okay I kind of thought it might be
something like that but I was trying to
limit how silly I sounded so I just
didn't try it thank you for telling me
though and if I mispronounce anyone's
name please let me know how to pronounce
it and I'll do my best to remember that
and pronounce it the right way every
time
Himanshu says what to learn to start
making websites HTML CSS and JavaScript
that's what you need you learn those
you'll be good and you can build you
build anything with that delay B says
what back-end should I learn with react
there is no job with no js' and I don't
want to do PHP I don't know I mean if
you can't find a job with node what else
do people use for back it's like Python
there's a whole area that uses like
dotnet framework with c-sharp so I mean
that you know maybe that would be my
advice MD Baba says hello that daily at
what time the classes begin and I want
to learn from starting how can I learn
you know what I the I'm assuming you're
talking about these live streams you
know we've been starting at such weird
times so I can't really say it'd be nice
if I get back on a normal schedule but
right now just too many things are going
on that I can't stick to a certain time
so unfortunately there is no set time
right now saying shout says many people
use coding as an escape as a way to find
another route in their life hope whoever
is doing it finds passion or luck along
the way yeah that's cool learning how to
code definitely has helped a lot of
people just you know have a totally
different lifestyle
a lot of times you know for the better
Ilyn Bala says I strongly suggest Jonas
at you to me I took many before him and
Jonas advanced CSS courses the best that
I found thank you so much for that
recommendation so Jonas as an advanced
CSS course on udemy check that out rich
house is one of the prerequisites for
learning reacts JavaScript for sure I
mean HTML and CSS and JavaScript if you
know those you're good to learn react
Siddhartha's which languages are you
comfortable with and how did you start
your journey as a web developer
JavaScript I'm most comfortable with I
know a little PHP and I've done a little
bit with Python before with c-sharp Java
C++ like I've done a little bit with a
lot of stuff but I'm only really
confident with JavaScript and some what
may be confident with PHP
MD baba says please tell me I can
contact with you I want to learn you can
find me on like Twitter and I think I
have a link to my Twitter in the in the
description oh and I don't really do
like courses or anything like that so if
you have any questions I'll do my best
to help out but you know for right now I
don't I'm not doing courses although
that might be something that you know I
might do at some point okay Amelio know
wants to know what other CSS framework
do I recommend I mean I I use mostly
with your UI I like that if I'm not the
one react I use materialize CSS sorry so
I haven't really used a lot of other
frameworks so I don't know that I can
really give any good recommendations
outside of those ones
ruch Russia cache says codeigniter or
Lara vote as far as I know CodeIgniter
is pretty outdated correct me if I'm
wrong so I would probably go with Lara
golf over you these are both for PHP nan
who says which should I learned before
react JavaScript CSS HTML
so one says why didn't you use a server
list tech for your back-end cloud
functions firebase yeah we I thought
about that but you know it's something
that I wasn't familiar enough with that
I was confident in doing it in a project
of this size you know in this of this
much importance you know so the way
we're doing it now you know for the most
part we've tested out before so felt
more confident than that MIT says make
some series of Kali Linux tutorial I've
never used Kali Linux so if I end up
using it maybe I'll do a series on it
Julio says hello Jesse
you should use saga or redux thunk I
have used thunk before I like it
I have not you saw this before
Julius says what do you think about
laravel is it a good to learn yeah if
you're gonna learn a PHP framework I
from what my limited knowledge about it
I do recommend Laura though I've heard
good things about it
sree says I'm currently working with
asp.net and Microsoft sequel server is
the dotnet framework losing at
significance what future do you imagine
is in store for dotnet framework I don't
really know I mean I'm not a huge fan of
dotnet framework but I see a lot there's
a lot of new stuff happening with it
even like Microsoft is really kind of
changing the way it interacts with the
developer community so you know I think
it'll be around for a while just because
of Microsoft really and there's so many
companies that are already kind of
entrenched in the whole dotnet world
it's not going anywhere anytime soon
so if it can be I think if the dotnet
world can be more integrated with the
rest of like the JavaScript dev world
and take advantage a lot of that stuff I
think it has a good shot at you know
being relevant and being around you know
for a long time so door says can I get
JavaScript tutorials at free code cam
yeah there's a whole course on
javascript on the free cookie org
website but then also we have a ton of
video tutorials as well on our YouTube
channel
andrew says hey Jesse site looks great I
saw an Instagram you're looking around
for the opportunities I'm sure you'll be
picked up in no time
oh thank you I appreciate it
Manu asks what's the best procedure for
learning react in a pro way online
courses I did turn off my music my
headaches getting so terrible I said
anything else we're doing a project in
that but looking at the documentation
makes that kind of difficult
freako can't pass some react stuff now
on freako keyboard
wow if you do like taking that yes I
would check that out there's definitely
a lot of good tutorial videos on react
out there so that might be a little bit
easier than trying to read the
documentation
sureiy says I'm mostly just fixing bugs
at work small issues arise out of
changes such additions to the codebase
is this what developers do in the US
yeah but it depends some developers main
job is fixing bugs it's maintenance
other developers build new stuff and
don't handle you know live you know
products so it just kind of depends
juggernaut says Jessie if you could
choose where you want to go what's your
dream I don't even know um I don't know
I have to think about that yeah I guess
it was like there's different parts to
that so it's like right now like I
always got to think about like my fame
my wife and family you know it's not
just like where do I want to go that
would be awesome it's you know where
could I go that would be the best for my
kids that would have good schools and
things like that so it's kind of a
complicated question
because I have to think about all those
things so yes I'm not exactly exactly
sure I mean in terms of work though I
love working on cutting edge stuff and I
love working on things that that would
actually help people
Sidora says I'm learning JavaScript but
I don't know where to implement that I
mean I want to work on some projects
from where should I get one yep check
out the free code camp curriculum
because they'll have a lot of sample
projects where you'll be able to use
JavaScript on I would recommend that
that's a good place to start is it would
still be useful to learn jQuery in 2018
yeah you know what there's still a lot
of companies that use jQuery for their
website so knowing jQuery is still good
going forward I expect probably the use
of jQuery will go down because there are
other things taking its place so I don't
know what the outlook is like for the
future but a lot of companies depending
on how big they are and what the
industries like are very very slow to
change things so there's still going to
be jQuery jobs around for a long time
just because of that MIT says what
should I do so that people know me
really sorry I just can't quit yawning
so people know me in the IT field this
is what happens when you try to give up
caffeine I guess yeah
get involved online like I mean as a
developer like Twitter is a huge thing
so I don't know if it's the same with IT
stuff but yeah like get involved on
Twitter you know follow the people that
are the like leaders in your field you
know like retweet their stuff try to
interact that's probably that's a really
good you know good way to go if you can
like write articles like tutorials or
you know do videos like I don't really
write that much but I like to do the
videos you know volunteer to help people
go to conferences when you go to
conferences make sure you talk to as
many people as you can so all those
things will will
marlyn says have you ever noticed jake
eNOS when your background loads for the
first time with react I get no lag when
using the image tag but when I switch to
background image it takes about two
seconds to load yeah sometimes when you
use background image you can have a
little bit of jinxo
try not to use it hold on the same cool
I just got handed a like a print
brochure thing and so I can check it out
see if I want to use any photos for the
website and then they will get me the
photos so that's kind of cool
my team eater is very helpful like the
other people in this department are
super helpful sorry I was right in the
middle I think Oh the janking is with
the background image yes so using a CSS
background image definitely takes it it
stresses out the browser more than using
an image tag so you want to be careful
with that don't use it like a bunch on
one page try to make sure your image is
optimized and if you have a ton of stuff
going on on a page you maybe don't want
to use it trying to do like parallax
things like we're doing here right with
our remember what is called in CSS now
it's a property when you use a
background image that that makes it do
that so that can also cause some trouble
so if you disabled that you'll you'll
have a much better time of it so if you
notice let's say like that the image
isn't showing up first it could be that
like maybe you want to take that CSS and
load it sooner right so if you have the
CSS for that in a CSS file and it's
waiting it's turn to get loaded then
it's gonna take a while so what you can
do you can make that background CSS be
inline in the HTML and it'll load a lot
more quickly or
[Music]
if you don't want to put it like right
in the HTML tag you could just take it
and put a style tag at the head of your
document and put that above all the
other things that you you want to load
like all your files you're bringing in
and that's kind of like a little trick
to use for this stuff that's like users
will see immediately I mean and then of
course like the image size itself will
definitely have an impact on how fast it
loads too
Amelio naissance coffee coffee cut tray
says how has work like for attorney
software developers in the u.s. who are
straight out of college in the first six
months I honestly have no idea because
that's not the route I went
so I've never I've never seen it
okay so I got a pronunciation here so
wah-wah way ruh let me know if that's
the right pronunciation thank you so
much for let me know how to pronounce
that Jesse says or andrew says Jesse do
companies use create react app in
production how much I'm not sure I mean
it's it's pretty commonly used but I
couldn't tell you right now like of a
specific company that does use it so I
mean I'd I don't know I imagine yes but
I definitely have to look that up I
wouldn't want to say for sure without
without checking Sidora says how was a
Riley's JavaScript book for learning
JavaScript I want to have a handbook
kind of thing for HTML CSS that I can
memorize them I don't know I haven't
checked out that book so there is some
good there's a JavaScript book called
eloquent JavaScript that's really good
and then there's a book series called
you don't know J ass that also is very
good so they're available online but you
you can get them in print as well
so check those out siddharth says what
can I do to memorize HTML CSS three tags
and attributes just use them right I've
never attempted to memorize them like
just use them and if you code every day
with them you will remember them so
that's I think is the the best way to go
about memorization right because just
look them up and you will remember them
right the annoyance of having to look
them up will force you to memorize them
right it's so much better to do it that
way then they try to like sit down and
read a list of them right you may as
well be be actually getting coding done
while you're memorizing hopefully that
makes sense it's just like the best way
to learn a language is to actually speak
it be immersed in it you know like a
spoken language I think that's the same
way with a computer language right just
just use it and
look up what you need to and so you
don't need to look it up anymore Java
Oracle Python which one do I have to
learn for a job you can get a job with
any of them it just depends on what you
want to do so just figure out what you
want to do and then do a little bit of
research on what companies are using
what language right and and then you
know do a search see what how many jobs
there are for that and that should kind
of tell you
Phoenix is at you and Greg Vance yeah
I'm wearing red pants so I don't know if
you can see I'm wearing yeah I'm wearing
red pants yeah
they are if anybody is interested in
wearing the same red pants as me you can
find them there bonobos is the brand and
they're bonobos chinos I don't know with
exactly them the color isn't called or
anything like that but they're nice
pants if it were
and ruse Oh Andrew was talking to
somebody else
juggernaut says Jessie you want to
continue web development or you're
looking for other endeavors like system
games etc I'm thinking I'll probably
just continue with like react
development because that's most likely
what I'll be able to get a job in but
I'd definitely be open to other things
like game development sounds fun
anything that has to do with some like
new air stuff like machine learning
sounds really cool
you know like VR or AR sounds awesome to
work with so I'm open to new
opportunities I just am Not sure that I
have the skill set to get hired in those
positions right now MD bobis is a wanna
learn machine learning how can I learn
try out Udacity has some machine
learning courses I think they have some
free ones so try those out because I
think they're pretty good and see if you
like it if you really like it you want
to do their paid courses then those are
available too Julia says well I have to
to know object-oriented PHP in order to
start learning Laura Bell I don't know I
don't know enough about Laura Bell so
sorry part says what is your view on
Google versus Oracle if you mean like
the whole lawsuit that was going on
between us I think it's I saw it with
Google in that lawsuit so basically like
Google was using so Oracle owns the
language Java Google was using Java
an Android operating system and Oracle
sued them claiming that I think like
Google them a bunch of money for using
Java when because they own Java so it's
kind of ridiculous like if we start
saying that companies can own
programming languages that's just crazy
right it to me like if that's how
horrible it Oracle is going to do this
then you know people aren't going to use
it anymore right it's so that's like
probably an oversimplification of what's
happening and may I could be wrong so if
I'm wrong correct me please but I just
think it sets a bad standard if you're
gonna allow Oracle to kind of win that
that case Manus water says hi what are
the languages I should go for if I want
to become an ethical hacker as well as
get into Android development Java or or
Kotlin for Android development and as a
hacker like I mean you you just need
whatever you're trying to hack you you
need to know how that works so you I
would assume now I'm not a hacker so
this is assumption so you know don't
take it as the way to go
but I would assume you would need to
have more of a general knowledge of a
lot of systems and then you would need
to like seriously do your homework on
the particular system you're about to
hack Siddhartha's is there any direct
use of C language and web development in
web development not that I know of I've
never come across it but it you know
could be out there what about c-sharp
yeah c-sharp is used in like dotnet
framework stuff so I have come across
that in for the backend and web
development Lamballe o says have you
used react native and what do you think
about it as as a newbie learning react
I'm not sure if I should focus on
progressive web apps with react will
react native you learn react first
unless for some reason you really need
to make a mobile app I like react native
I really like
like building things react native and I
hope that I can do more with it in the
future so but I think if you're coming
from knowing HTML and CSS and JavaScript
trying to get into the reactor world
it's an easier jump to learn regular
react first than to go and react native
because there's a few extra kind of
things you have to think about when
you're building for for a mobile phone
right - building a mobile app right so
like it's a little bit easier if you're
still doing things to the web and a lot
of what you learn and react will help
you to learn react game yeah limbo
Lass's I'm focusing on mobile apps for
small business
yeah if you're focusing on mobile apps
then then learn react native first
because that's what you'll need
I know progressive web apps can be
downloaded on the home screen but a lot
of people just don't get that yet and I
don't realize that that's a thing so
probably you're gonna have a better time
of it and a better time selling your
services to small businesses if you use
a mobile app Siraj says can I go for the
react without - no js' yeah for sure you
don't have to use nodejs for react your
ad can be used with any type of back-end
we have another react versus angular
question so just can say it it just
depends on your project there's there's
no there's no quick answer for react
versus angular Marlon says thanks for
the help Jesse gonna try sorting this
background jank out by the way how do
you personally go about styling and
react stop components I have you stopped
components before but normally just use
like CSS and J's sometimes I use normal
style sheets sometimes I just do inline
Styles I do a variety of things I
haven't decided on what I really like
want to stick with yet Sidora says what
are the steps to become a full stack web
developer you can either start with the
front or the back end I started with
front end so I'll go over that HTML
Javascript CSS after that then then you
start to learn more about back-end stuff
so if you already know JavaScript I
recommend going with node learn about a
little bit about node how to set up you
know your your server your basic routing
maybe do like some handling of form data
emails things like that in node learn
about api's how to build api is how to
use api's like you know and branch out
from there right and I mean that's just
the JavaScript ecosystem so there's a
whole lot of other stuff if you want to
get into other languages and I'm sure I
mean I'm probably I'm leaving out a lot
of stuff right so but that's just the
basic route you take limb bala says
thanks so much for these so useful
answers I will be checking out your 200
plus other videos here yeah
if anybody ever manages to watch all of
my videos please let me know because
that would be I mean I've been around
for all of them that's a lot of content
write an apology because I'm sure I
probably have some like weird annoying
things that I do and
and having to suffer through all those
probably not the best Balaji says is
there any way to improve the speed
access of websites much faster than
regular scripts languages yeah there's
there's definitely a lot you can do you
know one of the biggest things that I
always do going in if people want me to
improve speed is checking image sizes so
many times it's that images are way too
large you know they're only showing a
tiny image but in reality the file is
actually huge image compression it could
be even like you know what's being
loaded and when is it being loaded
sometimes websites will have all this
tracking stuff so you guys are analytics
and then you got your social media
things that come in and they said way
too much going on and don't realize how
much it's it's impacting their site
right if you use like some third-party
things sometimes they're bringing in
whole libraries like and you don't even
realize like other versions of jQuery
and stuff just to do one tiny little
thing so like all of those things can
can definitely help out with speed you
can set up like a CDN and that will help
the speed so there's a lot of click
things you can do that don't really take
that much time but can have a huge
impact on your site speed I think I did
a video once where we try to take an old
site and make it faster or like a couple
of videos it may it'll be one of my
early videos on free code camp or it may
be one of my videos I did on my own
channel before I started doing free code
camp so I think there's a link to my
channel in the description if you want
to try to find it I do have some some
videos on there as well
soon meets bards vajra says what do you
think about reason ml and reason reacts
reason seems really cool when I went to
react rally ken wheeler gave a talk
about reason and that was the first time
I really like learn anything about
reason other than just hearing it and it
seems really awesome I don't know enough
about it to really give a good
explanation of it but it's something
that I would be open to using in the
future and I think it could help me
write like better better code so I'm
definitely I'm a fan of it but a very
new fan Suraj says do web development
there's web development of algorithms
and data structure in JavaScript not
really a lot
I mean algorithms and stuff like that
you need to know for job interviews
right but in reality like you don't use
them very much at all in day-to-day web
development so if you're not great with
them don't worry you can still be a good
web developer without being great at
algorithms siddharth says thanks a lot
for your for the answer is gonna watch
your javascript tutorials awesome yeah I
check out like on this on this channel
beau Karns does a ton of the JavaScript
tutorials that are awesome konstantin
says hey Jesse how long did it take you
to become a front-end and Lana first
shop so I was a freelancer for a while
so maybe like three years before I got
this full time job so like during that
time it's not like I was always looking
for jobs I was freelancing right so but
like I learned more and more as time
progressed and I picked up more clients
and try to do more challenging jobs so
it was like a three year period of me
slowly picking up new things but working
while I was doing
getting basically getting paid to learn
so I don't think it would always take it
certainly wouldn't take three years for
most people but because I was
freelancing while I was doing it I
wasn't really like actively looking for
for full-time like a full-time developer
position Siddhartha's keep teaching us
and Balaji says thanks for your
knowledge and is so useful oh I
appreciate you saying this every says hi
Jessie just watch the first ten minutes
in the streaming I'm really sorry for
what happened to you
hash tag we're with you thank you so
much I appreciate that make tutorials on
operating system programming it's hard
to learn I don't know anything about
that so I can only make a tutorial on
things I know about sir on chess thanks
for guiding us through live videos and
always up to live with Jessie mammy says
hello Jessie you're a great teacher and
I have learned a lot but still lost I
need help with JavaScript and learning
the codes now let me know I'm I'm about
to end the stream now but mammy you know
get a hold of me on Twitter or something
you can always ask me a question on
there as well
manus Foresters how to get started in
Android development you could if you
want to just do Android and you don't
want to do like react native then you
know try to find some Android tutorials
you're probably going to end up using
Java or Kotlin for that Siddhartha's
what is Franciscan Franciscan if
University of still is the college that
I currently work for Sarang says do you
have experience with machine learning
with javis get very very little
experience like I've done some tutorials
and watched videos on using brain j/s
and tensorflow j/s so I have some ideas
for stuff I want to build but I just
haven't built anything yet
a mod says afternoon JavaScript which
framework do you prefer a reactor
angular I prefer react but I don't have
a problem with angular I just I just
work with reacts all right I'm gonna end
things now I've been streaming for a
while and I think I've gotten so many
messages I keep saying my phone going
off so I'm gonna check these and
hopefully if there's nothing like major
that I need to do at work I'm gonna I'm
gonna head home for the day and and
relax a little bit Siddarth says you
made the Franciscan web site yes I did
to the website you see back here this is
what we made in live stream the whole
process all right so I see a few more
things coming up but I'm gonna I'm gonna
have to cut the stream off it there's so
many great questions I really enjoy this
but this this could probably keep going
forever but I I love all the questions I
love all like the the interest and
everything and I'm gonna try to do
another stream you know when I can and
hopefully after I do my react training
next week I'll have a ton of new stuff
to share with you about react so I'm
super excited about that and I'll
definitely let you know all the cool
stuff that I learned if anybody happens
to be in the DC area specifically in
like Tyson's Corner Virginia around
there let me know you know maybe we
could hang out next week or something
and yeah so until next time have a
wonderful day and thank you